the Joe Rogan experience ally came to
the set one day and sopranos I visited
he was a fan of the show and he he his
manager contacted my manager and I met
him in front of the studio and brought
him onto the set and nobody knew he was
coming and Gandolfini was like in bed he
was doing that when he was in the coma
there's all that stuff
he was like taking a nap between takes
and I brought Ali and the whole crew
just like froze and then I brought him
up to the bed and I tapped you Jim
turned around looked up holy [ __ ] he
hung out the whole day men took pictures
every crew people gave him a standing
ovation Wow he was such a star in such
an iconic figure that my parents who
were hippies they didn't give a [ __ ]
about fighting but when he fought Spinks
in the rematch they made us watch it we
were living in San Francisco look you
have to watch this Muhammad Ali is
fighting Leon Spinks he's gonna he's
gonna get his title back like it was a
big deal because he wasn't just a boxer
like it's hard for people to realize
that now in retrospect but when I was a
kid during the Vietnam War he was also a
symbol of the resistance to this unjust
war that we didn't want to be a part of
his a guy who lost three years of his
career because he wouldn't fight in the
war and so they stripped him of his
title in his prime like he beat
Cleveland big cat Williams probably the
finest performance of his young career
and then for three years he doesn't do
[ __ ] until he comes back
and you know was it was a he was more he
transcended sports oh absolutely the
world all over the world and and he got
his due I think so I you know what I
mean he's he's recognized as that guy
yeah you know it finally happened it
took a while but yeah oh there you go
that must have been on the set yeah it's
the hospital bed behind
that's crazy can't make up some [ __ ]
here they get right on yeah that's good
Jamie gets right on your ass hey [ __ ]
come up with the goods
he's also a cautionary tale for boxers
you know if you think that getting hit
in the head has no consequences when you
know towards the end of his life it was
very hard to watch sure yeah he wasn't
talking that much but he was very
present like he was with it he just
wasn't yeah neurologically he wasn't
capable of like really speaking it well
the dick Leon Spinks also mm-hmm
everyone Joe Frazier towards the end of
his career yeah horrible - what - watch
him and listen to him the only one who's
avoided that George Foreman woman to
this day George Foreman speaks great
he sounds normal
[Applause]